el día más largo del año en juneau
alaska es junio 21 el cual dura 1000
96.5 minutos medio año después cuando
los días son más cortos los días duran
alrededor de 380 y 2.5 minutos si no es
un año bisiesto el año tiene 365 días y
junio 21 es el día 172 del año encuentra
una función trigonométricas que modele
la duración l del día de del año
entonces va a ser l en función de t
suponiendo que no es año bisiesto te
invito a que le pongas pausa al vídeo e
intentes hacerlo por tu cuenta antes de
que lo hagamos juntos bien hagámoslo en
vez de encontrar directamente el dt voy
a encontrar
ld donde v es una variable digamos
intermedia que me permite construir una
función que en principio es más simple
precisemos esto donde
son días
después
días después de junio 21 veamos esto en
junio 21 en junio 21 cuánto vale
y son los días después de junio 21 así
es que vale 0 mientras que t t es igual
a 172 pues nos están diciendo que junio
21 es el día 172 del año entonces cuál
es la relación entre 1 y t es
simplemente una traslación de 172 días
es decir y es igual a t es igual a t
menos 172 cuando te vale 172 no vale
cero así es que primero vamos a obtener
ldv para después sustituir un porte
menos 172 para empezar qué sucede cuando
es igual a cero déjame escribir todo
esto que sucede cuando es igual a cero
cuando es igual a cero es 121 que es
cuando ocurre el valor máximo y cuál es
la función trigonométricas que toma su
valor máximo cuando
cuando su argumento es igual a 0 seno de
0 es igual a cero mientras que coseno si
toma su valor máximo en 0 me parece que
de alguna manera el modelo se facilita
si usamos la función coseno así es que
el edu va a ser igual a una constante
que va a ser la amplitud x coseno de un
argumento que va a estar dado por otra
constante ya me molesté no mejor vamos a
llamarle b dado que usamos a una
constante b que multiplica a mi variable
v más otra constante que va a trasladar
la función hacia arriba o hacia abajo
así es que esta es la forma que tiene la
función l de eeuu y ahora tenemos que
determinar el valor de las constantes
para empezar consideramos la amplitud y
la línea de en medio la línea del medio
va a establecer que tanto hay que mover
la función hacia arriba para esto
saquemos la calculadora la línea de en
medio se va a ubicar a la mitad entre
estos dos números tenemos que 1000 96.5
+ 380 y 2.5
entre dos esto es igual a 730 y 9.5 ese
es el valor de ce así es que se es igual
a 730 y 9.5 ahora la amplitud indica la
variación que hay con respecto a la
línea de en medio podemos calcular
entonces 1000 96.5 menos esto o esto
menos 380 y 2.5 hagamos eso 1000 96.5
menos el valor que acabamos de obtener
700 39.5 no 730 y 9.5 y así obtenemos
esto es igual a 357 es la variación que
hay con respecto a la línea de en medio
357 a es igual a 357 ahora cuánto vale b
para esto hay que considerar el
comportamiento de la función cuál es el
periodo de la función para ver esto voy
a hacer una pequeña tabla aquí
así es que cuando y cuando vale 0 es
decir 0 días después de junio 21
queremos que nuestra función sea el
valor máximo es decir nuestra función
queremos que valga 357 que multiplica al
coseno de cero
más 730 y 9.5 ahora cuál es la duración
de un periodo un periodo es un año
completo cuando los días tienen la misma
duración esto es un poco de sentido
común así es que después de 365 días
cuando es igual a 365 se ha completado
un periodo se regresará a ese valor
máximo así es que el valor de la función
es igual a 357 que multiplica al coseno
de 2 y si estamos considerando la típica
función trigonométricas coseno y este
ángulo fuera un valor de theta
cualquiera el periodo es 2 pi así es que
el valor de la función corresponde a
esto que estoy escribiendo aquí más 730
y 9.5 y ahora podemos establecer que de
x 365 es igual a 22 pies igual a b x 365
vamos a escribirlo por acá
x 365 esto de aquí tiene que ser igual a
2 pi esto es igual a 2 pi despejamos b
dividiendo ambos lados entre 365 con lo
cual obtenemos que ve es igual a 2 pi
dividido entre 365 ya que así la tenemos
ya encontramos a b y c y lo único que
tenemos que hacer es sustituir o igual a
tm 172 para obtener nuestra función de t
hagamos eso y aquí merecemos unas
fanfarrias tenemos entonces que el dt es
igual a
357 que multiplica a 12 no debe que es 2
y sobre 335 coseno de 2 y sobre 365 que
multiplica no a la queremos en términos
de t no en términos de días después de
junio 21 sino en días del año así es que
multiplica a t menos 172 y eso
más 730 y 9.5 y así hemos concluido
parece una expresión muy complicada pero
si la analizas como lo hemos hecho en
términos de los valores máximos y
mínimos con respecto a la línea de en
medio y haces ese análisis cuando el
argumento de la función es cero o dos pi
de hecho es mucho más fácil con cero y
después ya te preocupas por la
traslación no es tan difícil en fin
espero que este vídeo te haya sido útil